There are situations when it's hard to know what to say...
...or how to approach someone.
The best thing to remember is to be as little invasive as possible.
This means not asking questions like...
..."Who are you?," What do you do?," or "What's your name?".
And definitely never ask anyone about his or her age or marital status.
To comment about a person's appearance can be very tricky.
The biggest blunder in etiquette...
...would be to comment on a person's size. This would be considered extremely rude.
It is best to talk about something neutral.
Cliche and boring as it may sound, this is why "the weather" is such a common starter.
An attempt at neutrality sounds like unoriginal advice,...
...but think about it: You are telling the other person that you are not invading their privacy...
...and because you are talking about something fairly irrelevant,...
...you are testing the other person to see if he wants to get to know you better.